there's really only one word that can
accurately sum up my thoughts on this
film blood 300 rise of an empire is a
sort of sequel not really a sequel not
really a prequel it takes place in the
middle of the timeline of the original
300 men screamed there was lots of blood
and boobs and blood and boobs and abs
and blood and boobs and abs and men
screaming and lots of blood that's
basically what 300 was and it was a good
time it was a lot of fun some people
really loved that movie I wasn't a
die-hard fan of the movie war I loved it
so much but I did enjoy it and I did
have fun with it and I thought it was a
good manly time at the movies this new
one is very similar to the first one in
style in substance basically it's the
exact same type of stuff that's going on
and it's done with just about as much
skill in this movie the students
Themistocles is going against the
Persian army and Artemisia played by Eva
green as well as a man turned God who
was in the first 300 and this film you
get a little bit more backstory about
him and how he got to be the way that he
is and this movie is surprisingly better
than I thought I was going to be because
even though I enjoyed the first 300
something about this one just looked
really bad there wasn't really that one
star in the movie that I could latch
onto that I felt I had some connection
from the first one it seemed like it was
a different story then it got pushed
back way farther than its original
release date so there were a lot of bad
things with this movie that just looked
like it wasn't really gonna be that good
but it actually was a lot of fun there's
lots of blood there's lots of battles
there's lots of slow-mo to fast moe but
the reason it didn't bother me as much
in this film is because this is the
movie franchise that got that started
the original 300 really went forth with
that fast most slow-mo thing where
everyone's going really fast like that's
basically what a lot of this movie is
like the original 300 popularize that
filmmaking technique but since then it's
kind of become overused like in January
with the legend of Hercules and so
there's an aspect of this movie that
feels dated in the way it's filmed even
though it's within the franchise that
started it would be like have a new
matrix film came out and they were doing
all the bullet-time effects it wouldn't
be as interesting or as visually
revolutionary as it was the first time
around and that's what happened with
reloaded in revolutions you're like yes
we've seen this before
it's never gonna be as interesting as
the first time in this film suffers from
that because
inventive visual style that 300 use is
now kind of old and so it doesn't really
feel as interesting in this film even
though I can accept that it's there
because it's all done very well the CGI
is convincing enough even though you
know that basically everything in the
background is CGI the guys are good with
their stunt work and the men are good at
screaming and that's really what you
come for you come to see men slicing
open stomachs and heads and everything
and my goodness that is definitely
present there is a lot of blood in this
movie and I'm sure that fans of that
will not be disappointed that being said
the main hero in the movie was kind of
disappointing I didn't really feel much
for him I thought that he was kind of a
boring character he wasn't very
interesting as a person and he basically
gave a lot of really good battle
speeches and was cool to watch in battle
by far the most interesting character
and the one that I enjoyed looking at
the most was Eva Green's character I
thought she had a great backstory
you actually kind of felt for her as a
villain once you learned about the
things that she went through and you
kind of understood why she is as evil as
she is even though she does that cliched
killed members of her own army thing
where it doesn't really help you when
you do that you know I know you have a
lot of people at your disposal but
killing them all when they make mistakes
doesn't actually help overall 300 rise
of an empire is a suitably entertaining
movie if you are a humongous fan of the
first 300 I'm sure you'll find things to
enjoy here if you just thought the first
one was entertaining I'm sure you can
watch this one and still feel the same
way the main hero is not as interesting
as in the first 300 he's a little bit
boring but he is good in the action
scenes and he's not a bad actor he does
a good job with what he's given it's
just that as a character I wasn't really
that invested in it there's a lot of
good backstories for other characters
though like Eva Green's character and it
has a very good musical score as well
it's a fun movie to look at there's lots
of blood lots of swordplay it's nowhere
near as good as the first one but it is
still an enjoyable time and it's better
than I thought it was going to be I'm
gonna give 300 rise of an empire of B -
so guys what are your thoughts on the
first movie or the second one how do you
think they compare let me know below and
as always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and gets Domino's
[Music]